hey youtubers is charlie so comic-con is
almost here it starts tomorrow
officially but Game of Thrones doesn't
start till Friday so this is going to be
a breakdown of what to expect from this
weekend there's a couple really notable
people that are going to be missing from
that panel on Friday including Kit
Harington george RR martin dan and dave
martin already explained that he
canceled a lot of his convention
appearances this year just we can finish
wins a winner dan and dave had just
started production of season six
comic-con is like a couple weeks earlier
than normal this year so they're just
now starting to roll footage for next
year kit harington tin foil theories
aside he and carice van houten mel
sandra they're filming a big blockbuster
movie this summer so they're probably
often pre-production on that I just love
the idea that Jon Snow and malice and
are making a movie together and everyone
wants to see him make a shadow baby
together we just keep our fingers
crossed on that one for the most part
the game of thrones panel this year will
be just like last year the cast will do
the QA it's typically filled up by the
QA but they usually bring a casting
video for the next season for like the
biggest five or six characters that they
cast and the blooper reel I will say
those two things I'm definitely more
excited to see some of the people if
they've actually cast there was some
news a couple weeks ago about people
they were looking to cast I already did
a video on that up i'll put a link in
the description but that's all
unconfirmed like those are just like
casting descriptions not actual people
so hopefully they actually show us who
these people are as much fun as blooper
reels are I feel like most of us will
watch the game of thrones panel wanting
to know what's going to be going on next
season the big star the panel last year
and I feel like one of the biggest stars
at comic-con period was Pedro Pascal
just because his performance was so
great and he was involved in so many big
WTF moments normally i would say that
Kit Harington would be like the Pedro
Pascal of this year like oh my god I
can't believe what happened to you talk
about it what was it like he's
conveniently absent so i feel like nazy
williams has a chance to steal the show
because she had that just amazing kill
at the end of the season Maren effing
Trant too bad he's not going to be there
here's the full lineup though here's all
the people that HBO is bringing there's
reek Samwell Brienne sir Davos Margaery
Tyrell Ferris Gilly Sansa Melisandre
isn't that interesting because if
making a movie with Jon Snow why isn't
he at the panel too and then are you
obviously Maisie Williams in place of
Georgia are Martin Dan and Dave they're
sending David Nutter he's the guy that
directed the finale so the interesting
thing about this list is that nobody on
it can tell us anything about whether or
not Jon Snow is going to be alive in
season six none of the actors know and
David neder probably doesn't know either
so that a lot of people that think that
they're trying to create the
circumstances to avoid Jon Snow talk at
comic-con even though that's probably
going to be every single question on the
Q&A panel Margaery Tyrell you had some
great scenes this year what do you think
happened to Jon Snow Ferris you traveled
around a lot with Tyrion what do you
think happened to John snow lots and
lots of Jon Snow questions i would
actually hope that the people that just
wander into the panel waiting for other
panels also ask about jon snow even if
they have no idea who he is it's just
that every year whenever a big actor
gets killed off they always come to
comic-con to say oh you know it was such
a fun ride I had so much fun filling me
my death scene it was crazy I can't wait
to see what they do next season I'm sad
to be gone even if you're not a book
reader they're just like there's so many
clues that the show has been dropping
that Jon Snow is not going to stay dead
they keep saying he's dead right now and
I think that's correct but that doesn't
mean that he won't be resurrected so
spin all the fan series you want in the
comments I'll include a link for my
resurrection video in the comments just
it just explains all the resurrections
that have happened in the Song of Ice
and Fire so far the really huge bummer
would be if they don't bring anything
for next year like if they don't bring a
casting video it's really early in the
year so it's possible that they haven't
found the actors they're looking for yet
they wouldn't come completely
empty-handed and they have they have
found most of the directors for next
season and most of those people have
said that they've read all the scripts
so they've written almost every single
episode for season six meaning they know
what the story is going to be so
hopefully David Nutter or someone behind
the show will give us some hints about
what's going on even though it is going
to be like the beginning of wild
departures from the books like they've
changed some stuff from the books in
season 5 in season 4 season six is what
they're calling like the first
completely off book season although
technically there's still some book
things that they haven't done yet that
they probably will include so what's
going to happen is they'll have their
big hall h panel on
friday night i'll post the entire panel
video after that ends and if they post
like a trailer video or a casting video
I'll do a separate video for that so be
sure to subscribe to get everything I'm
also doing a new round of the giveaway
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so just a reminder my Game of
Thrones videos from comic-con won't post
till friday night I will be live
tweeting during the panel though so if
you want to follow me there my twitter
and facebook links are in the
description it's gonna be a lot of fun
they're gonna be a lot of crazy people
asking a lot of weird questions don't be
surprised if there are a lot of people
that just ask questions that don't make
any sense that's kind of the way it goes
it like really big fan panel Q&A is like
it's it's not like a bunch of experts
asking really specific questions about
next season and they usually screen
everyone so they don't let you ask
spoilery questions if there's any really
big surprises that I'm hoping to see it
would be a surprise appearance from jon
snow or like some sort of video message
that he taped like oh we're all sad the
kids not here but he sent this video for
us to give to you guys where he just
says something funny to all the fans
even if there's not a lot of Jon Snow
stuff going on I feel like Maisie
Williams could still talk a lot about
the Faceless Men which it which is just
like another really exciting thing
inside the game of thrones universe
they're gonna continue to explore here's
my question for you guys what do you
really want to see them do at the
comic-con panel like do you want to see
them talk about really crazy stuff that
happened behind the scenes or do you
want to hear them just talk about season
six if you are going to comic-con I'm
gonna be doing a meet-up that will
probably end up being Friday night it
might be thursday night i'm thinking
it'll be friday be sure to check my
Twitter and Facebook for announcements
on that because that'll prob anon the
fly I will be working all week like all
the way from monday to sunday but i will
try to break for a meetup just for
anybody that's there and if you do see
me walking by you're welcome to come up
and say hello you can you can either
call me emergency awesome or Charlie you
know whichever you're more comfortable
with so best of luck to everyone going
and if you're not going don't worry just
keep your eyes peeled on my YouTube
homepage I'll have my comic con playlist
up at the top so while you guys wait for
all the rest of the comic-con videos to
come you can click here for like my
master comic-con playlist that's just
where I'll put all the panel videos all
the preview videos i'm doing the trailer
videos everything and you can click here
to learn all about resurrection in the
Song of Ice and Fire thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys this week
you